the unmade Souls born videos it's this
long document I have full of video ideas
that sounded better in my head
videos that didn't inspire me to start
writing or ideas that I just haven't
gotten around to yet and it's sad but
true this list is where videos go to die
but there is potential here and of all
the videos in this graveyard I'm going
to let my patrons resurrect one in three
days I'll release a poll for $1 patrons
and above and you guys my most trusted
supporters can vote on which one you
want me to make so with that said here
other unmade Souls borne videos of 2017
first up is the great Wars of dark souls
of all the videos on this list this one
would probably teach us all the most
about topics we haven't talked about
before because not all the wars fit into
the context of the characters that I
usually discuss so in this video there
would be the major Wars and there would
be minor Wars and both types are
interesting for the major Wars we would
have things like Lorex
so-called Civil War which we haven't
talked about in a long time and we would
also have lorian's war against the
demons and there's even vendrick's war
against the Giants which bears
mentioning especially because we never
really determined for sure what vendrick
stole from the Giants and then there's
the minor Wars and they're champions for
example the land of mirror was so
experienced with war that vendrick
actually enlisted their assassins to
kill for him and he also bribed away
their legendary blacksmith Llewelyn with
the promise of a lifetime contract in
exchange for all of his incredibly
advanced techniques these things helped
them win the war we could also talk
about furrow Samand they're champions as
al the north water or shield less sleep
iron and there was also a storage war
against the evil eye which was
vanquished by a nameless noble hero and
finally we would also have the first
foray against the Giants led by Sir Sian
who failed so spectacularly that he
haunted all of those
would wear his armor from that point on
and I bet you haven't heard a lot of
those stories especially on this channel
so that would be fantastic because these
are little stories that I could never
really justify a full video for this
video on the great Wars would fulfill
and enrich the world in a thousand
smaller ways next exposing the art
thieves on Facebook so the few times I
do browse through Facebook I often end
my session in this blind rage because
the most common advertisement I come
across is this [ __ ]
kinda Dark Souls Dark Souls fans yeah
right whoever runs these pages is
undoubtedly making thousands of dollars
from stealing the work of artists in our
community here's what they do they troll
tumblr and deviantART for great Dark
Souls art then they just copy and paste
a design onto a t-shirt from a company
like T chip or T hard and then they dump
a ton of money into Facebook advertising
so that their campaign finds all of us
you know with Facebook's incredibly
advanced tracking techniques it finds
all the Dark Souls fans and shoves this
stolen art in their faces and you know
it surprisingly hundreds of these
geniuses on Facebook actually like the
post and they tagged their friends and I
assume considering the t-shirt makers
can afford all this advertising I assume
they actually buy this stuff without
questioning where it's from now the
other scummy thing is that these t-shirt
and poster campaigns
they're usually time limited so even if
the original artists DMCA claims it and
tries to get it taken down by the time
the site takes action the user has
already made a profit from that campaign
and they've moved on
there's no campaign to take down anymore
and its really [ __ ] disgusting and
there's not much you can do
Facebook refuses to take down the pages
because there
profiting from all those ad sales scummy
sites like t chip and t hard don't
really respond to customer complaints
because they're selling t-shirts and
somehow thousands of Facebook users are
okay wearing the sole of Sinda copy
pasted onto a low-quality hoodie how do
you fight against those people who buys
this anyway I've left a link in the
description to these pages so feel free
to do your part in the comment sections
and just raise awareness amongst the
people who are tagging all their friends
I hate to see it in the long run though
Namco Bandai's legal team is probably
the only way for this to get solved
because only they can consistently file
takedown requests on these Facebook
pages I have passed this information
along and they didn't do anything so I
probably need your help to put an AAMCO
email in the description as well but you
know what would really hurt their
profits and their success competition
good competition if there was a better
merchandise page that actually paid
artists for their work and then used
those profits to out-compete the thieves
with Facebook ads then we could actually
make a dent in their earnings now I
would do this but then I figured Dark
Souls merch is probably in a bit of a
legal gray area so yeah
I suppose if patrons vote for this video
and want to see a bit of justice then
I'll pursue these ideas a little more
and really try to get it taken down or
really try to out-compete these guys
anyway
it feels good to get that off my chest
finally next video titled the shared
timeline of souls born so a long while
ago I read this great article by James
win on Game Zone regarding whether Dark
Souls blood-borne and Demon Souls share
a timeline and it almost inspired me to
share it with you and just build upon
that idea a little bit now before you
laugh at the idea I have to say
ultimately I do disagree with the idea I
don't think it's plausible for multiple
IPS owned by different publishers to all
be a part of one cohesive story and I do
think it's a little bit dishonest to
cherry-pick only evidence that suits
your narrative and just ignore all the
evidence that doesn't I have to say you
can definitely make a surprisingly good
argument for all these games being a
part of the same world and regardless
it's actually really fun to craft these
kinds of arguments and the act of
crafting this argument would be a really
fun challenge the basic premise is that
the bad ending of demon souls below the
Nexus leads to the beginning of Dark
Souls and that the increasing references
of blood throughout the Dark Souls
series eventually lays the foundation
for blood-borne so in Demon Souls the
old one is this unfathomable entity not
unlike the great ones from blood-borne
located deep below the earth and
approaching you from this enormous ocean
the old one enlists the help of lesser
demons and servants to feed its Souls
and in the selfish ending the fog of the
old one enshrouds the world allowing it
to feed upon and contain the soul of
every living thing fast forward many
years and you could argue that it is
these very souls that form the first
flame the souls of Lords are entombed in
this tree like kiln of the slumbering
great one
and as Dark Souls progresses there are a
few blood-borne references that are kind
of hard to miss
first there's marvellous Chester who's
dressed almost identically to a hunter
and even admits to being pulled from a
different timeline then in Dark Souls 3
we get our first hints that souls are
actually contained within the blood
courtesy of the abyss Watchers and then
later in the ring City DLC where the
primeval Dark Soul is found within the
blood of its first Lords and within this
blood a new world is painted and the
world of man and the great ones collides
once more and to blood-borne
there's a ton more to talk about here
like how a medieval set of armor can be
found within Blood Bones tombs of
tomorrow or how strikingly the
monumental makes the old one sound like
an eldritch great one but that will have
to wait for the full video if my patrons
vote for it and honestly I really hope
you guys do next
the etymology of souls names so
etymology is the study of the origin of
words and the souls games are a
fantastic candidate for this field
because Miyazaki is really really
consistent in the way that he names
characters and places in fact the names
of almost every character and place in
souls can be traced back to their roots
particularly in elvish a fictional
language devised by JRR tolkien whose
worlds are undoubtedly this force of
inspiration for Miyazaki because we all
know how well read Miyazaki is in other
fantasy worlds and how liberally he
tends to take from these other creators
youtuber pontus was the first one to
bring this to my attention and he
corrected a potentially incorrect
interpretation of Fillion Noah's name in
one of my ring city videos turns out
fountas has 10 videos in this series now
and it's really really fulfilling to
break down character names and just
learn a little bit more about the
character in the process of doing that
some of my favorites are Gwendolyn where
the elvish Sindarin for Guin Bhagwan
means pale or maiden and Dolan means
secret or hidden the hidden pale maiden
and the Quenya word for fur are fara
meaning hunter and arm being high an
intensifier unit of language which can
imply holy sacred undying heavenly so
where fara means hunter and arm is the
intensifier this could become the hunter
of the heavens perhaps and as we talked
about in my last video the war god forum
could well have been another name for
the nameless king
who was this god of war who fought the
everlasting dragons so a hunter of the
heavens would be a fitting name indeed
for such a character there's a lot of
potential here and I hope you guys see
and I should probably note just because
you see these videos here doesn't mean I
won't find a way to talk about them in
the future
one example is an idea that I floated
with for a long time this year to make a
video on the games I enjoy outside of
souls and there's a lot of them to name
a few for onna pub G fortnight Gwent
breath of the wild star G Valley neo
cuphead these are just some of the games
that I loved this year my favorite being
Gwent which I still play and I think I
have the perfect format to talk about
them coming up soon after you do YouTube
so long it's really really hard to enjoy
a game and not want to share it with
people it just feels really unnatural so
there'll be a video coming on that sort
of thing soon because it's not all about
Dark Souls which leads me to my next
video idea and a question that's on all
of your minds what comes after Dark
Souls 3 not just for this channel but
for the game in general and the short
answer is that from software isn't going
anywhere they aren't going to neglect
their core audience with their next few
games that wouldn't make sense from a
business perspective and I'm definitely
not going to neglect any opportunity to
help us all enjoy their games more so in
that regard for the channel and the
games it's just a matter of waiting I am
a hundred percent sure on that if you
don't want to wait for that longer
answer on what comes after Dark Souls 3
for this channel and everything else
then you'll have to vote for this video
because I have a few big projects in the
works that you're kind of gonna have to
force me to share because the one trap
you can really fall into is hyping
something up and then something goes
wrong and you fail to deliver so I'm
kind of just keeping a lot of things
secret right now one thing that will be
really easy for me to share is another
video on translations and this one would
revolve around the first Dark Souls
again like
previous video and this episode would
talk about the abyss and safe perhaps
more than anything else this video is
actually already fairly scripted so I
could get it out pretty quickly
and as a bit of a teaser for it did you
know that in Japanese the primordial
serpents are actually called the world's
servants which is a name that harkens
back to a lot of Nordic mythology there
would really be quite a few
groundbreaking revelations in this video
just like the one on izalith another way
apart from translations that we could go
back to Dark Souls 1 would be with mods
there are some now that can completely
change the experience of playing there's
this randomized weapon mod which changes
all the locations of items and
guarantees you'll have a completely
different build at the start of the game
than you're used to having then there's
the weapon swap mod which does a similar
thing except weapons are randomized on
your character every minute or so
there's also this gun game style mod
that upgrades you through this series of
weapons based on how many hits you get
on an enemy and downgrades the quality
of your weapons based on how many hits
you take there's a limbo mod which
really challenges your knowledge of
layout and animation adding a ton of
shadow and removing all color which just
makes a more challenging play through
and the newest addition there is a boss
rush mod now which is incredibly fun you
get to customize your character and see
how far and fast you can make it through
every boss in the game in this gauntlet
rush the download is unfortunately not
active as of the making of this video
however and I'll put a link in the
description as soon as access is back
but to finish off there are some videos
that are too good to rush and these are
ones that I do plan on May
for sure first up Edward and the pants
the movie which is an intimidating
project but exciting and there's a
crossover video with game theory that
will come out eventually but it's on
hold right now there's two videos on
game design which in particular focus on
level design and the concept of death in
souls and finally something I really
want to talk about but I shouldn't a
hugely ambitious project on blood-borne
that is currently in the works I've
received countless requests to go back
to blood-borne and I will but when I do
it I'm gonna do it right but thank you
for watching and thanks to any of you
guys who became patrons as a result of
this video in order to vote in the poll
and thank you to all patrons who
believed in what I'm doing here and what
I will continue to do in the future I'll
see you in our resurrected video cheers
guys
[Music]
you